I wish you all the best for the future
and look forward to seeing you again
thank you very much got me Sydenham must
come please thank you very much good
afternoon thank you so much Minister
this was the second time I said goodbye
to the trade ministers this time I think
it's for real
so this was most likely my last trade
council and that is of course was very
special it's been five fantastic
dramatic and challenging years and many
things we discussed today have been on
the agenda for many years as well as the
minister said we start to talk about the
WTO the upcoming ministerial conference
what is possible realistic achievable to
incur sheave by then the joint European
strategy and of course the most the most
acute issue the applet body where the
European Union will continue to push the
process in Geneva but also in relations
with other countries and with the u.s.
to see if it is possible to find a
solution by December and if not pursuing
our interim agreements to preserve our
rights in WTO dispute and try to find a
long-term solution and we will also
continue to see how we can reform
strengthen and modernize the WTO in all
its form because the crisis in WTO is of
course much bigger than only the the
applet body as the minister said we
discussed the eu-us trade relationship
trying to see where the areas where we
can maintain a positive and balanced
agenda the good news is that the u.s.
did not announce any new tariffs on EU
car and car parts on the November 13
deadline set in their investigation so
this means that both sides continue to
respect the agreement done by presidents
in current Trump of last July where we
said as long as we have this positive
agenda we would not impose any new
tariffs of course the threat is not
entirely gone and we are mindful of that
we discussed the Airbus Boeing issue the
EU has we are disappointed by the US
imposition of tariffs we will have the
possibility to impose bow
tariffs next year once authorized by the
WTO but we would prefer and we have made
this very clear to the US to say that we
should find a solution to future and
existing subsidies on civil aircraft and
also see if we can find some joint
global standards because they are the
countries who are massively subsidizing
their their industry and on a positive
note we are on track to implement the
agreement with the US on the specific
charile hormone-free
beef quota we hope the European
Parliament will vote yes to this next
week and their Council with them endorse
it beginning of December we have sent to
the US a proposal for a text on an
agreement on conformity assessment and
we are also working on some some
standards and we are waiting for a
response to the US on this we are happy
to to note that the EU Singapore
agreement enters into force today this
is good news for EU and Singapore but
also for the whole region because this
is an important stepping stone for us
and Singapore is also an important ally
when it comes for instance in the
reforms of WTO and the modernization of
the the international framework as the
minister said we discussed new China
relations in a broad sense I was happy
to see that my successor and friend and
colleague Phil Hogan signed and agreed
finally in being last week on the
protection of geographical indications
meaning that 100 traditional delicacies
will be protected for an imitation in
China and we will give the same
protective protection for 100 Chinese
products this is important for many of
our member countries and their economy
and we will continue discussions and
negotiations in our investment
negotiations with China we are partners
in some areas but we're also competitors
so we need to deepen the engagement with
China while defending our interests and
this is certainly a discussion that will
come back during the the next coming
as well and finally I presented as I did
yesterday
the Eurobarometer survey where we can
see that actually a majority of EU
citizens 60% percent think that they
benefit from international trade this is
a race with 16 percentage points from
2010 and 70% say that EU is stronger
together when they negotiate trade their
member states on their own and 80% agree
that we need strong international trade
rules this is a very interesting
Eurobarometer I will invite you to look
at the details there so it was a very
intense and interesting and important
council today thanking the Finnish
presidency for the way you led this and
the way you're leading that the
presidency overall and and of course
looking and wishing you all the good
things